okay good let's try this again my name
is torie Grable and Sharaf machine
learning at UCL and I work as a research
scientist at deep mind it's a startup
company that tries to solve problems in
artificial intelligence this course is a
collaboration between UCL and deep mind
to give you the chance to learn about
those machine learning techniques that
are likely to help get us to artificial
intelligence here's the overview of what
I'm going to cover we'll talk a little
bit about the structure of the course
and and the team the people who are
offering the course we have guest
lectures given by some excellent guest
lecturers which we you will get to know
over the course of this module then
talked about a deep mind approach to AI
I think I would like you to know where
we're coming from when we talk about
these things what we want to achieve and
why we think that the particular things
covered in this module might help us get
to artificial intelligence or as we try
to ambitiously call it general
artificial intelligence I'll then talk a
little bit about deep learning and I'll
then give two very short nuggets of
project work one about learning to play
Atari games using deep reinforcement
learning and one about alphago which is
one of my favorite projects finally have
some extra revision material we
restructured the course from last year
last year this material was covered in
two lectures and I've appended most of
the material here we might not get into
that but if you're interested and want
to prepare for the following lectures
you might want to take a look at this
material in Moodle there may be time to
highlight a little bit of it okay so
let's dive right in here's the team the
that put this course together and will
also deliver it Cora is the head of our
deep learning group and he has sponsored
all the deep learning talks and has
helped us put this together my colleague
Hado will give the reinforcement
learning track of this module which
mostly takes place on Thursday at the
inhumane time of 9:00 a.m. you may have
noticed this in the schedule you know
that's real self selection anyone going
to at that time I mean I have the
highest appreciation I certainly won't
be there well maybe sometimes okay and
then a number of other people played a
key role there's material Hessel and
Alex Davies
they're our tensorflow experts and
they'll give the tensorflow tutorial on
thursday to give you a good basis for
the for the course work which will
decode it intensive low and who've also
helped together the course work
assignments Deana borsa can you wave who
is coordinating the TA support she's
also a research scientist a deep mind
and Marie who helps us with the general
organization Marie
where are you very good and also
coordinates the recordings and then we
have some amazing teaching assistants
any of these here yeah can you wave
visibly okay
who will help with the course work
assignments okay so that's the team
let's talk a little bit about the format
and the assessment so we have these two
streams and we have a deep learning
stream and a reinforcement learning
stream and towards the end they will
somatically converge to some degree and
these are the basic building
blocks in what we think is needed to
build AI systems based on machine
learning and on Tuesdays mostly we'll
have guest lectures on deep learning
topics and I'll talk about what that
will be that later and on Thursdays Hado
will give a structured introduction to
reinforcement learning and also there
will be two guest lecturers at the end
of this so that's roughly the structure
but there are some exceptions so please
check the time table we have a schedule
posted on Moodle so one question that
sometimes comes up is how does the
assessment of the course work last year
we had 5050 coursework assignments and
written exam but we found that it was
tricky to formulate really nice
questions based on the cutting-edge
material that was being presented and so
we thought it would be a better
experience for you all if you can just
focus on the programming assignments
really work on those deep learning and
RL practical problems and learn rather
than having this this exam hanging over
your heads so the idea is basically that
we'll have four deep learning and four
reinforcement learning assignments these
will be spread across the weeks here of
the module and then these eight
assignments will be weighted equally and
the final grade will be based on those
assignments these questions will be
mixtures of programming assignments and
questions of understanding that that you
will answer in this context to make
things really easy we decided to put the
entire course work this time into collab
so collab is is a jupiter notebook
environment where you don't need to do
any setup this is just connected to the
cloud we can pre configure it and we are
also providing the computational
resources that you'll need to solve the
tasks this is again going back to
student feedback from last year or
it was difficult for people to procure
enough computational resources to do
everything they wanted to do and so this
time we're trying to make the design the
assignments more carefully and at the
same time provide the computational
resources that you need for you in the
cloud will use tensorflow as mentioned
before and you can find more information
about the whole assessment on Moodle one
thing that we needed to do in order to
set up this collab resources is that we
white listed a bunch of email addresses
with the collab service and in order to
use that we would like to ask you to
create a gmail account or Google Account
here with this form at UCL CompTIA 22
2018 and the XS represent your student
ID and we've pre white listed those so
that if you register this account you
will get access to the collab service
also we thought it would be nice if you
have a new a fresh account for this that
you can use ok then finally regarding
support we would like to encourage you
to use Moodle for all your support
queries if you want to discuss stuff
there's a Moodle forum lecturers and
teaching assistants will will look at
these questions and answer them
ideally other students can answer them
we want to share the answers to these
things we would like to avoid any
one-to-one communication where questions
would be answered multiple times the
answers would be shared and so on if you
have some kind of personal trouble then
feel free to email me with with that
problem but but please not with any
material that could be of interest to
others as well ok any questions about
the format and the course work get used
to asking questions please makes this
thing so much more entertaining for
everyone no do you think stupid
questions are funny
smart questions are useful yeah yeah
it's just the these digits it's usually
eight digits and for people who have
been added a little longer I think it's
seven digits yeah that one okay so just
to show you what this collab looks like
so this is the interface to collab you
have these cells that you can work with
and you can code directly in Python in
these cells and there's code cells and
texts also the the assignments will come
in the form of such a collab notebook
and it there will also be some code
available there already that you can
plug your own code in to make you to
have some kind of unified visualization
and and plumbing code available and we
hope that that will make the whole
programming experience nicer for you and
then we'll ask you to submit this
notebook for each one of those
assignments together with the PDF print
out it's all detailed on Moodle what
exactly is required and submission
ideally on time makes everyone's lives
easier and the grades better good and
tensorflow
we probably all know tensorflow it's
this google open source software to
define and run machine learning
algorithms mostly used for neural
networks that's pretty standard thing
and I think we will all benefit from
getting exposure to this unless you've
already had it and there are some great
jobs out there for people who know how
to do tencel oh good a little warning
this course we had some feedback on it
it's pretty hard
people were really unhappy last year not
everyone but some of them were so if you
do not know how to code in Python maybe
this isn't the right course for you if
you do not have some of the
preliminaries required in machine
learning in maths statistics and so on
maybe this isn't the right course for
you to think carefully about that and we
created a little self-assessment quiz on
Moodle that you can take a look at after
the lecture if you can do the majority
of that without problems then you're in
the right course if you struggle with
those questions then you might struggle
with a lot of the lectures and maybe
there's there's a better course
somewhere for you to catch up on those
things unless you think you have a lot
of time on your hands who thinks they
have a lot of time on their hands right
to catch up on some of these issues
good let's look a little bit at the
schedule yeah
what's the question
but please do stay if you feel up okay
so we here's a little schedule for the
course you'll also find this on Moodle
you can see here that we have basically
these two tracks the two state track on
deep learning and the first day track on
reinforcement learning and we have some
some very exciting lectures lined up
here and the deep learning track they
are a little bit heterogeneous from from
the topic perspective because each of
these lecturers is an expert in the
field they present cutting-edge stuff
leading up to the things that they do in
their research so there's really a
goldmine off of knowledge to be gained
here from these lectures but of course
you do need to understand the basics
very well and when they go through some
of the basics in the particular topic
that will be relatively quickly so they
can go up to the really interesting
stuff on the other hand the
reinforcement learning path is a little
bit more structured because this is
given by one lecturer Hado who also is
an expert in this field and and this has
more these building blocks that are
actually building on top of each other
and we think that is also more
appropriate because very few people
would have had real exposure to
reinforcement learning here and so this
is from the ground up so what you see
here on the right are the weeks in which
we're aiming to distribute the
coursework assignment deep learning
coursework PLC w124 and real
reinforcement learning coursework 1 to 4
so we're trying to distribute this
across the course time as good as we can
of course we need some startup time to
get going and to to get you some of the
information that you need but then we've
spaced this fairly evenly to the end
the course that again is is I think an
improvement over last year where there
were bigger chunks we hope that these
smaller chunks will encourage you to do
that work right away
so that you can get the feedback on this
work you can see how what you're doing
connects to what you learned in the
lectures in a more immediate way than if
you wait to the end and then then do
that work okay do we need a more more
seat here here's one more seat do you
want to take that okay so let's go
through the program in a little more
detail because we really have some
fantastic speakers and that also gives
you a little exposure to the topics so
on Thursday we'll start with this
introduction to tensorflow
which hopefully gives you a foundation
for the coursework that you'll be
expected to do it will be delivered but
by mateo hassle and Alex Davies and
basically they'll give you an
introduction to tens of love principles
and then they'll also do some work
through examples in collab and then
later make that collab available for you
to play with then following through with
the deep learning track of things the
next lecture will be given by Simon
Austin Darrow and he will cover newer
networks multi-class classification how
backprop works how automatic
differentiation works how tensorflow
does it for you and so will deliver the
basics on on neural networks in this
lecture and he's a really a real expert
on this so I'll probably just attend
that again because the basics are
explained so well okay so then the next
lecture will be on convolutional neural
networks again we have an expert on the
topic heron built one of the important
neural network architectures that led to
a great improvement on image net on the
object classification benchmark and he's
going to talk about convolutional
networks applied to large scale image
recognition and show you how these
models can be applied to image net as an
example and how the architectures have
evolved and how to train those models
the next topic is recurrent Nets and
sequence generation so whereas
convolutional neural networks assume in
some sense that there's a 2d topology
that of an image or some other grid may
be a go board often we see data in
sequence form for example text but other
time series as well and there are
specific neural network architectures
recurrent neural networks that can deal
with this the most successful one that
he'll talk about is the LST M Network
and he'll also talk about conditional
sequence generation by the way he's the
the person who is driving the Starcraft
research at deep mind you may have heard
that we made available an environment
for doing research on Starcraft
are there any Starcraft players here
anyone yeah so I think that's that's a
pretty exciting domain so maybe he left
some time to talk about that as well I
don't know I'd have to see
good then riah we'll talk about end to
end an energy based learning she'll just
discuss some other structures other than
just simple regression losses for
example how to define losses for
embeddings how to define losses when you
have relations between three data points
that you want to embed if if you want to
do ranking and and similar questions
then the topic of optimization presented
by James Martin's optimization of course
is one of the major tools in machine
learning it was actually a major step
for me
learning nowadays maybe few people know
this but machine learning used to be
based on rules you know people would
just define learning rules and hope that
the system would then somehow converge
to an interesting solution for example
kohonen maps are an example of where
someone just formulated a biologically
plausible rule in order to find low
dimensional embeddings of data and that
was always problematic because there
were no convergence guarantees and so on
so now of course optimization is at the
center of machine learning and this
lecture will be dedicated to
understanding better what kinds of
algorithms are out there and what
properties they have including force
first order methods second order methods
and very importantly also stochastic
methods for dealing with very large data
sets where you might want to subsample
examples or take them in very small mini
batches good will then move on to more
advanced topics Alex graves will talk
about attention and memory models so the
starting point where newer networks were
basically the simple feed-forward newer
networks but over time people have
developed more and more sophisticated
modules that can do more and more
interesting things and attention and
memory are two of these elements
attention is basically the ability to
focus on some subset of your inputs in
order to concentrate your processing
power on those ideally words
particularly interesting and memory
models in some sense can be seen as
turning that to the inside when you have
some internal memory and you then turn
attention where while reading it to
particular parts of that internal state
of yourself as an agent if you like and
alex is an is an expert on this he
developed the these ideas of the neural
Turing machines the differentiable
neural computers and in this lecture he
will lead you up to the point where you
can understand how these things
we'll then have a lecture on deep
learning for natural language processing
given by IDI at grayish data and this is
mostly an application lecture and
there's actually an entire series of
this lecture because quite a rich topic
but these neural language models neural
word embeddings these things are now the
state-of-the-art methods in neural
language processing in natural language
processing and he will explain how these
things work and how neural networks can
successfully be applied to text finally
we'll have a lecture on unsupervised
learning and deep generative models of
course this again is a very complex big
topic and we could have an entire
lecture see a series on that topic but
we think it's important to to give you
some exposure to the latest stuff there
many people think that unsupervised
learning is going to be very important
going forward among other things because
we just don't have labeled data for all
the domains that we would like to look
into but we have vast amounts of data
that I unlabeled if you just think of
all the data on YouTube if we could
learn from that that would be great
right but we have very poor labeling on
that maybe titles of videos but that's
not really what this is about right you
want to go into the video stream and
learn from that and so that's a huge
topic very important for AI Chuck here
is an expert and he will explain ideas
around this and in particular also about
deep generative models models that can
actually produce data for example image
data or text or similar things okay
that's yeah
sorry can you say again see well I mean
yeah so if these are latent variables
and that's the the observation then this
equation I think he put it there because
he thinks that represents basically the
the deep problem of unsupervised
learning - given these observations why
to discover these these latent causes
zette that produce them and so I think
he would argue that in some sense all of
unsupervised learning is captured by
that equation okay then this is about
the other stream the reinforcement
learning stream led by hado
and he'll talk more about that when he
starts lecturing next week about roughly
about the things he's going to talk
about an introduction to reinforcement
learning of course discussing what
Markov decision processes are which are
the underlying framework for doing
reinforcement learning he'll then go
into planning and how to do planning
using dynamic programming where there's
no learning aspect yet just planning in
a given model it will discuss model free
prediction and model free control he'll
then discuss value function based
methods in contrast to policy direct
policy optimization methods and how to
integrate learning and planning he'll
discuss exploration versus exploitation
which is this problem that comes up for
the for for these agencies reinforcement
learning agents that act in the world
and have to somehow strike a balance
between gathering new information that
can help them improve how they can act
in that world versus exploiting what
they already know in order to gather in
order to gather immediate reward and
then towards the end for the last two
lectures
were planning to guest lectures the
first one on alphago given by David
server have you heard of alphago okay
that's good
so I think that will be of interest and
David is fantastic speaker I hope we can
win him over for this and the second
case study is about practical deep
reinforcement learning deep
reinforcement learning is really this
point of convergence where deep learning
and reinforcement learning come together
because we're using neural networks to
represent either policies or value
functions for reinforcement learning in
a very flexible way by function
approximation and Vlad nee is the lead
author of the paper where this was
applied to to these 50 Atari games a
couple of years ago three years ago now
I suppose and he will tell you the
latest about deep reinforcement learning
how it worked with the atari games what
other domains are out there what other
algorithms are out there and so on okay
Wow
it's a rocket it's good so any questions
about the plan so far plan is clear good
so why is there rocket let me see if I
can remember
so we're now moving to the part about
what deepmind does and how we approach
our mission and the idea really is to of
creating deep mind was to create
something like an Apollo program for
artificial intelligence now a program
were really large numbers of researchers
would be focused and would be able to
make rapid progress on this problem of
of AI and the mission is really crisp I
think two words solve intelligence and
partly what we're also experimenting
with is in addition to the machine
learning stuff is how to organize
science itself because it is actually a
rather tricky problem to have a large
number of scientists and have them work
together towards a common goal and we
think we have found good ways to do this
which are somehow at the interface of
how it's done in academia and how it is
done in start-up companies and in some
sense the idea deep mind is to combine
the best of two worlds in order to
really create an environment in which
rapid progress towards AI can be made so
the basic premise of our work is that AI
can really only be achieved if we can
understand how learning works AI we
think will be solved by learning
algorithms and this of course comes from
experience from the past because in the
past in what we call good old-fashioned
AI other approaches were tried more
rule-based approaches were tried where
people would would build systems by
combining different rules and bits of
knowledge from humans added to knowledge
bases or added to the program and this
turned out to be very difficult to
scale because these bits of knowledge
tend to then interfere with one another
it's also remarkably difficult for us to
actually formulate what we know about
the problem alphago is one example of
this even if you are a go player are
there any go players here it's very
tricky to explain why a move is good
isn't that I mean you make it you have
this gut feeling you can come up with
some kind of explanation but it's really
hard and so formalizing by hand
knowledge about tasks that we're good at
is really tricky on the other hand we
have learning algorithms and if we can
feed them with examples of what we want
to learn that is a much more powerful
approach but of course the world is an
interactive place so we will not just
have input-output examples for all kinds
of problems that need to be solved and
so we need to create algorithms that can
go out there into a world be that a
simulated world or the real world that
can interact with that world and find
out for themselves what kind of behavior
is optimal towards their goal and so
that's the general idea
but there's another thing that we would
like to do we want generality so in
order for a system to be truly
intelligent we think it should be
general it should be applicable to
different domains to a wide range of
different domains and only then would we
really be calling it intelligent if it
can only do one thing then it might not
be really that intelligent and of course
currently most of the work that we see
most of the successes that we see would
qualify more likely as narrow AI AI that
is aimed at solving a particular task
rather than a wide class of tasks and so
we want artificial general intelligence
intelligence that can address address
many different tasks the important
conceptual tool that we use is
reinforcement learning and we really
consider this to be a general purpose
framework for AI because
it encompasses this idea of an agent
interacting with the world and learning
from their interaction so the basic
setting is that we have this agent and
we have an environment and that they
interact in these two ways the agent can
observe what's happening in the
environment or what the environment is
the state of the environment and it can
then issue actions into that environment
in order to change that environment
and the goal of an agent is to maximize
long-term reward
long term is important here because most
of the interesting things that we want
to do require maximizing long-term
reward if you want to get from A to B in
some city you don't get immediate reward
you get the reward when you were there
when you arrived so to speak so you need
to plan long term in order to get from A
to B and there are many other examples
we can also think of this setup as
encompassing supervised and unsupervised
learning as special cases because nobody
forces the agent to actually submit any
actions and so if you if you think of
this actions block not being there then
we have the environment and the agent is
just learning about that environment and
getting some kind of some kind of reward
function according to its goal oh
there's actually this is a little so
yeah you can also think of some kind of
reward you know part of the observations
here to be some kind of reward signal
that the environment gives to the agent
yeah yeah that's a that's a good
question but you could think of some
kind of likelihood criterion maybe that
no day that's right there it's it's not
clear but I I would argue that if you
come up with one then I would be able to
put it in this schema but it's it's
clear that it's you know for example if
you wanted to do test likelihood then
there you would have the the agent would
request examples and we'll see examples
and could build a model internally and
then the it would request test examples
and then the environment would issue
test examples and it would get rewards
based on how well it predicts that so I
think in that sense it's it's a very
general framework of course it also
weakness of the framework that is so
general right because it it gives less
guidance as to how to solve these things
good
so reinforcement learning and you'll
learn a lot about this from Hado since
the goal of our research a deep mind and
maybe the goal of some of you will be to
create intelligence it's an interesting
question to ask what is intelligence and
our chief scientist Shan lag together
with his then PhD supervisor mark Sutter
came up with this definition here based
on mining hundreds of definitions they
had found in the literature it's
actually quite an amusing paper to read
so they have a paper where they look at
all kinds of definitions from all kinds
of sources of what intelligence is and
then try to distill out the main
properties that they think should be
present there and here's what they came
up with intelligent measures an agent's
ability to achieve goals in a wide range
of environments
does anyone strongly disagree with this
statement
yeah that's interesting isn't it yeah
yeah so this this in some sense assumes
that the goals are given externally
where as truly intelligent beings maybe
generate their own goals to some degree
but then maybe that could be specified
as a meta goal from the outside yeah
it's it's a bit tricky well what I tried
to do here is to be very operational in
some sense and I would like to explain
to you how this motivates to large parts
the research agenda of deep mind into
intelligence and that's based on this
equation which I think just looks
beautifully if you squint your eyes I
mean it's just a beautiful beast a bit
of texture here so let's take a look at
this so they define this measure of
intelligence as a function of the policy
PI you can think of this policy or
alternatively as an agent that acts in a
particular way in an environment in any
environment reading and so the way they
define it is through this value function
here which is at the core of it and this
expresses basically how well does this
policy or this agent do in this
environment mu so that seems like a good
idea if there is a given environment
then an agent that does well in the
environment would be if there was only
that one environment more intelligent
that with respect to that environment
then an agent that there's less well
right so that that seems plausible of
course it still depends on how we
measure this but now this is summed over
a set of environments E and waited so
what this expresses basically is the
diversity we said that intelligence
would be required to be successful
across a wide range of environments and
so that is the set of environments here
and this factor now here
says hey but they're not all created
equally some of them are more important
than others and the way this is
formulated here is that this is - - the
- the Kolmogorov complexity of the
environment and the idea here is that if
the environment is simple then this term
is large and there's a high weight on it
and if the Kolmogorov complexity is
large then this term is low now one
advantage of this formulation is that
this sum converges which is always a
nice thing for a theoretician right you
know if your system you're talking about
isn't infinity it's a nice thing but it
captures the intuition that there are
fewer simple problems and if you call
yourself into an intelligent agent you
want to at least score well on those and
then they're more of the complex kind
because they require more description
lengths to specify them and then if you
want to be more intelligent you need to
do better on many of those and I mean
we're not really like a human there's
only there's only one big world so how
do you like this yeah yeah it's that's a
good question so as they formulated this
is the set of all computable
environments such that this quantity can
be evaluated but in practice and that's
the important thing for the research
agenda is we define sets of environments
and then we try to do well on them so we
take this as inspiration we don't
actually want to solve this particular
thing it's just you know too hard but
the way we view it is why don't you we
pick sets of ever more complex tasks and
try to train our agents first on the
simpler one and then make that more
complex and more complex and get them
ever more intelligent according to this
definition and so one example that you
could take is maybe there's a simple
block based game that you start with and
then you move on to the Atari games
which are visually more complex and have
more interesting dynamics and then you
go to 3d games that I yet require more
from your agents but no one tells you
the boundary yeah yeah if you want to
really look at it for the human it's
very difficult and I think it's an
interesting open question how to do this
so we in some sense we interact only
through our body with the environment
and where do our rewards even come from
in some sense they're self generated
through our brain and then how is that
controlled well evolution developed us
in some sense evolved us and there were
certain forces that shaped the anatomy
and the chemistry of our brains and so
somehow there never is in a reward that
can be totally isolated if you look at
this complex story it's just all
evolving and the environment is changing
and you are a part of my environment and
I'm part of your environment and you
know that year so this is definitely a
simplifying model where were where we're
trying to say suppose there were these
there was this nested for almost set of
environments we could where they were
all well defined can we come up with a
definition of intelligence within that
limited few yeah so it's also maybe
slightly counterintuitive the more
complex the environment is the less
waitis it has it's interesting yeah this
is these other people have had these
concerns as well and that's definitely
interest
but the idea here is that you should at
least nail the simple ones and then you
can move on to the more complex one but
if you got any single more complex one
because there are so many more of them
you in order to really make progress in
terms of intelligence you need to be
able to self solve many more of those
yeah that's the problem there are
exponentially many more of the higher
complexity steps so if we weighted them
all even more this sum wouldn't even
converge but yeah it's it's a bit
counterintuitive maybe it could be
captured somewhere in the value that you
achieve that the more complex ones maybe
give you more value for now let's take
it as an inspiration to think about an
approach where we have environments on
the one hand side that we can construct
and we have learning agents that we can
put into these environments and train
and we basically want to cover our bases
and be able to have these agents be
successful in the simple ones and then
we want to ramp up the complexity of
these environments and be able to solve
ever more complex ones you can also
think of it as a curriculum if you do it
in that order because there's no order
implied here but I would recommend
starting with the simple ones and then
moving on to the more complex ones as
humans often do during their lifetime as
well yeah yes also interesting you might
have it in the V right for example if a
complex policy was encoded through a
complex neural network which would
require a lot of energy to evaluate then
if your task was to come out of the
environment with your maximum amount of
energy or survive as long as you can in
the environment then you could code that
all in the actual environment and reward
combination and a simple as small and
your network would then be advantageous
because it's actually better at the task
because the task involves resources and
it's better at preserving resources okay
but you see you can get into a lot of
discussions even at the point where
you're trying to say what you're what
you want to solve so tricky questions
okay so if we think about our own
intelligence then certainly it didn't
evolve in a purely abstract world it is
grounded in rich sensorimotor reality we
see things we can manipulate things and
we know that for example babies learn in
this way and to get some some of this
people have looked at games video games
as a particular set of tasks that are
really nice for this purpose and a lot
of the work that we do as you know Atari
games alphago is based on games and I
personally think they're they're a
fantastic platform for AI algorithms so
what are the advantages these are
basically simulators right the game so
you have unlimited training data anyone
doing machine learning surely
appreciates that of course it comes at a
cost
when you run the environment it also
costs your resources so there's a
trade-off in some sense you need less
data but you need computational
resources but me we can run these in
simulation and that has a lot of
advantages because we can have many
instances for example in training we can
have thousands of computers run the same
thing and train and that's very powerful
if you compare that to a robot arm that
is much trickier because then you have
to deal with the mechanics of the arm
you need physical space to put the arms
you need to maintain them they might
change over time and so on so working in
simulation is really attractive and so a
lot of the work that we do is in
simulation now of course the death
advantage is that it's not the real
world so we might be missing out on some
aspects of the real world like
measurement noise changing changes in
the dynamics stuff breaking you know the
real world but the idea here is we can
make progress maybe first in these more
abstract games domains and then we can
move to the real world later so the goal
in these domains then is to do
end-to-end learning agents and basically
we want to formulate an algorithm that
observes the world in some sense issues
actions in interaction with the
environment and learns how to solve the
task without further input from humans
and that's how the the Atari work came
about and I'll talk a little bit about
it later
but that's basically the the research
philosophy that we're trying to follow a
deep mind and which we think is a
promising way towards developing
artificial intelligence good just see
the timing shall we make a 10 minute
break maybe and then meet back here five
past three all right thanks we just did
some online learning here and found out
that our instructions don't quite work
the way we intended them to hold off
with the creation of those Gmail
accounts we'll need to figure out what
exact characters Gmail addresses can
contain apparently dashes are not among
them so we'll we'll update that on the
assessment part of the Moodle page so
you can take a look also just to clarify
these coursework bits are individual
pieces they are to not to be solved in
teams if you know what I mean
of course it's always nice to advise
other students and help them in some way
but do it in very general terms okay
let's talk a little bit about if
learning deep learning is a hot topic we
when we think about it in the in the
context of artificial intelligence we
think of it as helping us solve this
perception problem that we want to want
our agents to be able to comprehend the
world to perceive the world and then
comprehend it but to perceive it at the
level of the sensors by which they
perceive it so for for video or images
on the pixel level the raw data and
while this sounds may be very natural to
you now again this wasn't exactly the
agenda of AI in the past which often
worked at a symbolic level and where
problems arose because it was very hard
to connect that symbolic level on which
certain manipulations were relatively
easy with the actual underlying sensory
motor reality because you might have
some idea of maybe how to build a tower
or something out of pieces but if you
just direct the camera at the seed you
first need to figure out what are the
pieces and and how can I move them so a
purely symbolic solution is kind of
hovering somewhere abstractly and it's
disconnected both from what you can see
in the world because it's hard to get
that symbolic representation from pixels
and to get it back into the world once
you've drawn some conclusions you want
to act in that world and so we want that
connection and it turns out that deep
learning offers very nice tools for this
because it is currently the framework
that is most successful
in processing classifying and so on
perceptual stimuli from from those raw
sources like audio or images or videos
so what characterizes deep learning one
big thing is that it is based on
end-to-end training so we want to
formulate a model and then train it end
to end say we have labels and images and
we just want the system to be optimized
end to end for this problem we don't
want to engineer features because that
would require human input for every new
problem we want these features to be
automatically learned we want the system
to learn good representations and newer
networks have come back so to speak to
be able to do all of these things and
are now very versatile can be applied to
images to text to audio to video to grow
positions whatever you like these
systems are modular in design so because
we do gradient based learning we can
stick together modules and pass the
gradients through these modules and
learn the parameters of the individual
pieces it's not that they don't have any
prior knowledge built in there are a lot
of different architectures and every
architecture of a neural network gives
the system some kind of some kind of
inductive bias or represent some form of
prior knowledge the most well-known one
maybe our convolutions convolutional
neural networks encode certain spatial
relationships in the inputs and
facilitate through that specific weight
sharing the processing of images which
for example of them have translational
invariance or localized features the way
deep learning has come about is it
evolved from normal neural
works but it was then enabled by having
more data and more compute power in
particular GPUs of course so if we look
at what's out there and we'll have more
lectures on the details of course but I
want to give you a little sneak preview
the convolutional networks pioneered by
Jung Lacan and others the basic idea for
processing images and making use of
these biases that I was talking about
and were successfully used for
classifying digits and handwriting on
postal coastal codes on envelopes in the
US Postal Service and of course this is
a comparatively small problem but then
the real breakthrough was that they
could also be applied to this huge data
set of image net image net is a good
example for how you can make a great
research contribution not just be by
creating new algorithms or delivering
new solutions but also by posing new
problems so image net is this huge data
set which has a thousand different
classes of objects and for each of these
1,000 different types of objects there
are a thousand examples example images
of those objects and this data set alone
has really boosted research in image
recognition and in particular in deep
learning so if you're ever in a position
to curate a really big data set it's it
can be a beautiful contribution to
science to do that and in 2012 there was
this big breakthrough of really reducing
the error rate with large convolutional
neural networks on this image net data
set bringing it a lot closer to human
performance now human performance has
been surpassed on that and and that was
really the kickoff point for the the
modern era of deep learning if you like
the neural these convolutional neural
networks can also be applied to
it's an interesting question why that
might be the case well text is also on
some kind of grid it's just a
one-dimensional grid it's a sequence of
characters instead of being a
two-dimensional grid of images and again
we can use the same kind of prior
knowledge namely that we would like to
have localized filters that can find
local features in the text and this was
applied both at word level but more
interestingly also at character level
and we can also we also have the shift
invariance that we have in images you
know if there's a particular combination
of characters here that that have a
particular meaning for example or
indicate a particular class then if that
is shifted somewhere else in the text it
might have a very similar meaning so so
those same ideas apply to text and hence
convolutional ideas can be applied here
as well and then of course you can go
one step further from images going to
stacks of images if you like to videos
and and again convolutional neural
networks have been very successful here
the author of this particular work is
Karin Simonian who will give the
lectures on convolutional neural
networks so you'll be able to learn much
more there what's essentially happening
is that you learn one big nonlinear
function and I would like to point you
particularly to this idea of viewing
deep learning as it as differentiable
programming I think that's a very
powerful idea you have to imagine 20
years ago or now 20 years ago nobody did
neural networks so 30 years ago and then
again maybe 15 years ago people had the
simple feed-forward neural networks to
approximate functions from input vectors
to output vectors and they had usually
they're a very uniform architecture you
know just fully connected layers one
after another trying to approximate a
given function what happens now is that
people define these modules and stick
them together you know
you can have convolutional modules you
can have Mary memory modules you can
have attentional modules you can have
fully connected modules you can have
output modules with softmax and so on
you stick together these building blocks
and you really program in this space of
models and of course you leave degrees
of freedom free and Emily the weights
the parameters within these models and
they can then be learned and to end by
propagating arrows through this system
and so I think that's a viewpoint that
is very useful to really think of it as
a new programming paradigm where we
leave a lot of the program unspecified
those are the weights that need to be
learned but we do encode the the
structure that we know into the neural
network recurrence of course is also an
element of that you know if you have a
recurrent neural network so in terms of
architectures you can see that people
have gone wild and have developed
different things starting from these
humble beginnings in the inception
network the topology was varied you know
you see these they're not just stacked
linearly in one direction but you see
there's different paths through this
network so there's almost like a 2d
structure to it in leather networks it's
an unsupervised type of system where you
have horizontal connections between
layers that facilitate learning locally
within each layer because every layer
doesn't have to wait to the out until
the output and then again the input is
reached through the propagation
there's rest nets which have this idea
that there's always two paths through a
layer there's an identity function that
kind of skips the layer but there's also
a nonlinear function that can then is
then used to fit the residual everything
that just stays the same it can be sent
through the identity and then this bit
can fit the residual and those are
stacked on top of each other so people
have really
lord various architectures and have
improved improved and improved on on the
metrics for example on on the image net
this particular thing came out of
Microsoft Research in 2015 the rest net
and made it made a big jump in the
performance numbers for for image net
but you see how this resembles
programming putting together these
architectures and of course framework
like tensorflow
is exactly designed to do that to stick
together elements and then leave leave
the actual implementation of the
propagation of errors and add gradients
to the system okay similarly in
unsupervised learning there was a
proliferation of architectures and
models restricted Boltzmann machines
autoencoders things that do PCA and ICA
and sparse coding sometimes stacking
layers of these on top of each other to
achieve hierarchy and of course a recent
favorite are also Gans which are a
beautiful idea in that they take this
single player problem if you like of of
matching or finding a density model a
generative model they turn that into a
two-player game where there's one agent
if you like that tries to produce
examples that look a lot like what you
want to produce and the other agent
needs to judge if that looks right or
not and needs to distinguish those
artificial examples from those give them
in the training set beautiful work so a
lot of stuff and we'll learn more as the
lectures continue then of course
sequence modeling incredibly powerful
the example that I like the most is how
you can formulate the simple task of
translation as a sequence transduction
problem it's just beautiful to view it
that way you have an input sequence
which is your text in one language you
have an output sequence which is your
text in
the language and you're really view
translation just as a mapping from one
sequence into another and at first
that's beautiful but people thought it
didn't work and then they found that you
can actually make this to work and and
now most translation systems are based
on these types of networks incredibly
powerful and also working at this
symbolic level of characters in words
and so on and oriole videos who is also
responsible for a lot of the progress in
this area will give the lecture on
sequence modeling okay that's the deep
learning overview and now I'll move on
to these two little bits of research to
give you some idea of what can be done
if you combine recent reinforcement
learning ideas with deep learning ideas
we will start off with the work on human
level control through deep reinforcement
learning
the work known as the Atari work if you
like which was one of the the first big
papers that came out of deep mind and I
think you probably have all seen these
the Atari games I think just discovering
that this kind of problem exists was was
a huge step and it was people in alberta
kay first came up with the idea
can we use a collection of these simple
Atari games that children's play that
grown-ups play admittedly and that can
be quite addictive and and interesting
can we turn those into a reinforcement
learning challenge and what's so
beautiful about them is that they offer
a rich visual domain you know this is
just one of them break out but of course
they are
a few dozen others and what they have in
common is the action space and the
observation space so they are really if
we can call them a family of problems
because when we observe the state of the
system we see an array of pixels or
stream of images and that's the same for
all of these games the content of those
images of course is different the way we
need to interpret them for each game is
different but the format is unified the
same holds true pretty much for the
action space imagine a controller a
joystick you can enumerate the actions
that you can make on this and so we also
have a unified action interface and so
we can really view this as a unified
family of problems we have many
different games and that going back to
the definition of intelligence gives us
the ability to train a system that can
men do many different things and can be
tested on many different scenarios now
how do we know these are interesting
problems they could be super boring
problems but no humans design them to be
interesting for humans so we know
they're interesting right they're
interesting in exactly the sense that
we're interested in here because they're
challenging for humans they become more
difficult as you progress they involve
manipulation you need to do the right
kind of combination of moves and so on
you need to understand conceptually and
so what's going on on the screen and
yeah it's a tough problem let us see
and again here by the way finding the
right problem is such a key skill right
if you can come up with a nice problem
that is close to solving then you're in
a beautiful situation okay
so putting this back in the context that
we had of the little reinforcement
learning diagram we can think of the
game as the environment and what we want
to build now is the agent the controller
and the agent will take in observations
from the environment which are these
images in fact what they do is they take
they concatenate four of those images
because they weren't a little bit of
history so to speak of what the past
looks like to see for example in which
direction the ball is flying you need a
little bit of a trajectory and then they
create this cue network which takes as
input those images and outputs for a
given state for every available action
this so-called cue value and we'll learn
more about that in the reinforcement
learning lectures but the q-value
basically indicates for each state how
good it would be to execute one of the
available actions in that state and then
of course you would want to pick the one
that maximizes that Q value and the
sense in which this move or this action
will be good is in the sense of long
term reward because the Q function will
represent the long term estimate of how
much reward reward you will get if you
execute that action in that particular
state so and and then you can imagine
this the training happens through the
interaction with this environment and
the results across these 50 domains 49 I
think we're quite stunning in that for
many of these games
the system reached human level or
superhuman level performance there are
also a few games for which that wasn't
the case and you can you can imagine
what the distinction is if you have a
more reactive game where everything you
need to know is currently on the screen
and you need to react immediately to
what's happening that's relatively easy
there's also a more direct feedback
signal there because for example in pong
if the ball goes by might get a negative
reward so so those are relatively easy
what is hard is if you have more of a
puzzle game there's a game called
montezuma's revenge I think it's called
so right you know what that means in
Mexico right the the the game is
basically more like a puzzle game where
there's a very narrow channel of actions
that you need to take you know there's
something you need to jump over and then
you must not fall into the thing but
avoid something and so on and so that is
very hard because the reward for doing
all that only comes much later when you
have collected a key and then gone with
that key later on through some door and
then you get a positive reward and so
that is very hard because the reward is
very sparse and very long-term and so
that's much harder to do and so but for
a lot of these games that algorithm was
successful you'll learn more about it
from from Vlad but it is really quite
nice to see its
how in this particular game the
controller has learned to to shoot the
fish if it collides with the fish and
then it loses a life and what you see
here is the value function and here is
the the Q value for each of the actions
that you could take up down left right
firing and so on and here is the so
called advantage function in time which
is basically the advantage each of the
actions has over the others technically
is the Q value minus the Q function
minus the state value function and it
uses basically this and takes the action
that maximizes this here and what's
interesting here is shooting the fish is
relatively easy and it will survives for
a while early models of the algorithm
didn't find out that once your oxygen
level is very low you need to go to the
surface to breathe to survive but then
as as research advanced and the training
was able to capture more long-term
relationships the algorithms also
figured out that that's what it needs to
do so short term shoot the fish evade
the fish but at some point when this bar
is low go to the surface get oxygen then
go back down just to point out how hard
this is because it's not maybe
immediately obvious and the system just
gets this image here and it doesn't know
what it controls so it doesn't know that
it is the submarine right it has no
about idea about that it needs to find
out that it needs to control this of
course we have no idea how it represents
that but somehow that's the task right
when we approach this game we wiggle the
controller and then we see oh I'm this
thing and then we have all kinds of
semantics you know we know that we
observe a collision with the fish and
then we
Oh colliding with fish isn't good oh I
can shoot and Oh oxygens probably up
there and not down there you know all of
this prior knowledge we bring to this
problem and that's why humans of course
also learn these games much faster than
computers currently do but it is
remarkable that computers can learn it
at all I think brother you had a first
I think millions of frames yeah yeah so
the problem is in order for these
problems to be formulated mathematically
you need to decay the reward so either
you have a finite you have a finite
sequence and you just add up all the
rewards but what we typically do here is
we have some kind of discount factor and
so we say that further away rewards
count less then more nearby rewards you
know a bit like interest rate and and
that decay factor pretty much determines
how far we take into account those
rewards but the problem is that you
might not even see them so you don't get
to train on the perfect trajectory where
at the end you get to see that reward if
you make the wrong moves and buy before
you never see it so it's also related to
the exploration exploitation problem
that you are the or the agent itself is
the data generator so if the if if it
never manages to even see a rewards
because it dies before hand or the
episode ends in some way then it will
never get that reward and maybe every
now and then because it still has
randomness in there it stumbles upon the
reward but then that reward is very rare
so so the Lord the problem with the
long-term reward is both that it's hard
to propagate it back but also when
it requires complex trajectories to get
there you might never see it because you
never get there there is some degree of
planning so when you see a reward it is
propagated through the cue function
backwards in time that we do much more I
think we we also get intermediate
rewards just by you know seeing oh I
move to the right and it moved to the
right yeah you know you get that kind of
satisfaction or you shoot the fish and
it disappears and you get that kind of
satisfaction here there are actually
some rewards for shooting fish so it
depends on the definition of the game
but the very hardest games have almost
no intermediate rewards and you only get
it at the end and those are the tough
ones yeah so that's that's a very good
question and I need to clarify something
that is maybe not clear here so what
happens here across these 50 games is
that the system is trained on each one
of them with the same hyper parameters
and so on and then test it on that same
game and the system is universal in the
sense that you can apply it to each of
those 49 games and test it on it and it
produces respectable results on all of
them there is not a single system here
that can play more than one game but in
the meantime people have worked on this
and they have created systems that can
play several of these games but it's
very tricky because suppose you want to
learn them in order you first learn one
game but now when you learn the second
game the learning updates for that game
destroy what you have learned for the
first one if you apply it to the same
neural network and so you either need to
mix the tasks so that you never forget
the old one while adding information to
the new one or you need to somehow
protect the weights that were learned
for the first game while learning the
second and
protect the ones of the first and second
game while learning the third and these
are very tricky questions it's called
lifelong learning and that's just
protecting those weights what you are
referring to those even further what you
would like to see is that you learn the
first game and you've now learned
certain concepts like moving left moving
right up down objects and now it should
be faster to learn the second one
because now you've already got some
prior knowledge from the first one and
that is that is an even harder problem
you want to transfer information from
one domain to the next but that's the
Holy Grail really that that would be
ideal if the system learned at a level
of of conceptualization so to speak that
the things it learned and the first game
would be useful for learning the second
these systems don't learn at that level
they learn more at the pixel level and
they never have this notion for example
of an object for example one of the key
things that you would really want to
learn about these things is that there's
this block somewhere and you're it and
when you move your joystick to the left
it goes to the left and when you move it
to the right it goes to the right those
things we currently have no way of
learning that but that's certainly the
future we need to learn at that level of
generality it's a great question yeah so
what it what it gets is with each
observation it also gets rewards and for
example if you just shot a fish then it
will get a little number and and it will
interpret that number as the reward and
when it dies it gets in a negative
reward or it stops getting a rewards
that's really all it gets but it's it
uses the sum over those numbers weighted
by that decay factor as as the
optimization criterion for its learning
yeah so they had if they are they are
here derived from the score
it's another advantage of this test
suite because the game designers in some
sense already provided the reward system
it's the game score and there are some
problems associated with it because for
each of these games those numbers can
have vastly different numerical
quantities and so the system needs to be
robust to that and they use reward
clipping for example or rescaling of the
rewards to make sure that they are all
roughly in the same order of magnitude
yeah yeah so this is so there is a
system called ale
Atari learning environment that
explicitly translates these games into a
reinforcement learning environment and
interpret this course that it finds as a
reward and segments those out yeah okay
now in some sense we're here in the very
early stages of you know the simpler
environments and many people have now
moved on although we're still using some
of these environments to test algorithms
that we develop but here's a newer
generation kind of set of environments
called deep mine lab and this is also
publicly available and constitutes a
kind of third first-person perspective
of some maze world where different tasks
can be represented what's nice here is
all of these tasks play out in some kind
of maze and the agents are in there with
the first-person perspective and see the
world from this first-person perspective
and and move in the same way so again we
have a family of problems that have a
unified input-output invar interface
they always see the pixels that come in
and the actions they take are turning
moving forward moving backward maybe
shooting I'm not sure
and now various different tasks can be
formulated within this environment and
agents can be trained here's basically
such an agent and when it interacts with
that world it gets the first-person
image of of what's of its position in
the world and it gets some kind of
reward depending on what it encounters
in that world and here the action spaces
can basically go forward backward turn
strafe jump up and and that's it unify
for all tasks within this task suite and
now you can see that this is a much more
demanding kind of environment here
someone navigating it you know apples in
this case give positive rewards and you
see the difficulty here is to interpret
this 2d image in terms of its 3d what it
represents in 3d and learn how to
navigate the maze based on certain point
things for example you see there's
images on the wall
so in principle once the agent has
navigated the maze for a while it could
have built up some kind of map knowledge
of the situation and if it finds itself
in a new spot in a spot then it might
orient itself by recognizing that
there's a particular image on the wall
and then it might draw conclusions about
what its best course of action would be
in that particular situation and there's
all kinds of interesting tasks that you
can do here
maybe mostly tasks related to navigation
because you would you know find the
Apple or walk through the maze and try
to collect as many apples as possible
things like that you can do but you can
also do other things for example
this is a kind of laser tag level in
space where the mode of movement is a
little more complex you have these ramps
where you can fly through space and get
from one platform to the other and again
put yourself in the position of an agent
seeing this and having to learn what
what it means what it sees it sees a 2d
projection of a 3d world from the
first-person perspective and somehow
needs to derive from that what actions
it would be advantageous to take in that
particular situation ok so much for that
and I think Vlad will be able to give
you much more insight into this and how
to address these types of problems
different algorithms and so on as the
last point for today I'll talk a little
bit about the alphago project to give
you some inspiration for some more
application of deep learning and
reinforcement learning I saw that we
have at least one go player here I'm so
glad strange though random ah see we
have to go players you could play maybe
you are playing and I'm just not seeing
it ok so go is it's a very different
type of problem so the the problems we
we just looked at in this labyrinth are
very much inspired by how we see the
world and interaction with the world
that is is naturally spatial where an
agent has a given position in that space
moves that position around has a
perspective that is tied to that
particular point of course go is a
problem that is different that is
difficult in other ways it's played on
this board as you know 19 by 19 with
black and white stones there's no agent
that you are in this game he plays
stones on the board in some sense stones
may be the agents but they're not
actually
so the player is the agent but it's not
so clear what the players representation
is other through which stones they
currently have on the board and the goal
of course is to surround territory in
this game and here the challenge is
quite different because here we have a
super large search space a huge search
space in fact represented by this the
game tree which has a game key
complexity of the breath to the power of
the depths of this tree so the breaths
is so many different moves you can
choose at any point in time and the
depths is how deeply you have to lock
down in the tree and the other problem
of course that needed to be addressed
here is one that it turns out deep
learning was suitable for namely to
assess how good a given position is to
evaluate the position and if you look at
the problem it's kind of natural that
you would think that that might be the
case because it looks a lot like a
vision problem you know you look at the
board it has a 2d structure like grid
structure like an image and so we know
humans are good at it or can be good at
it very few humans are actually good at
it but there are some humans who are
good at looking at the board and
determining for example if black has the
advantage or white has the advantage or
what would be a good move in a given
situation and and that's where were deep
learning comes in here's an illustration
of chess where you have maybe roughly 20
moves in every given position to
consider which is already a lot and of
course in go is many more it's up to 300
moves really so how is it done we use
deep learning and we have two types of
networks here one looks at the board and
finds a mapping from a board position to
an evaluation so it's basically trying
to estimate how likely it is that black
or white would win in a given situation
from looking at the board and the other
network is the so-called policy Network
which looks at the board and looks at
what might be good moves in this
particular situation and both of them
are visual tasks that humans can do we
know that a good go player can look at
the board and maybe at a glance see who
is in a better position sometimes it
takes more analysis to do it but what a
go player definitely can do is look at
the board and see plausible moves or
they do maybe they do the contrary they
say these they see a lot of moves that
definitely aren't good and they're not
going to consider so they select which
moves they're going to analyze more
precisely and those of course correspond
to particular visual patterns that are
not unlike the visual patterns that we
pick up when we do object recognition or
when we recognize faces there are
combinations of edges and areas and we
are now connected bits and pieces and so
it's not that surprising that a
convolutional architecture can actually
represent this mapping I still find it
somewhat surprising because if you
change a single pixel in a in an image
that never changes the semantics of the
image right there's almost no way it
could do that whereas if you change a
single stone on a goal board it might
very well turn it from a winning
position into a losing position and so
there is something specific about this
mapping problem it's much it's not as
smooth as maybe you think of the typical
visual recognition problems well how is
this use done and you can basically
think of the planning process here as
being represented by a huge game tree
and the problem of that is the game tree
is too big we cannot search it but we
can reduce it in two dimensions by using
the value Network we can avoid having to
evaluate all the way to the end when we
know the outcome of the game but we can
evaluate earlier and by reducing by
selectively only looking at moves that
look promising we can make the game tree
much more narrow and in that sense again
reduce the size of the tree and the
remaining tree if you
then is amenable to search techniques
that can get us good results using at
that point of paring down your tree is
it is it deep blue like exhaustive
search
it's called Monte Carlo tree search and
so it's still a little different Monte
Carlo tree search always picks one
trajectory through the tree and and
always develops a new node at the end
and grows the tree in this way so it's
it's different from what the blue would
be using which is a min Max search using
heuristic called alpha beta pruning
where it where it basically can
disregard certain parts of the tree for
logical reasons but otherwise has to
expand large portions of the tree so the
multicolored research does more of an
averaging so in min max search you
really have assumed that you have an
accurate evaluation function and one
player tries to maximize it and the
other player tries to minimize it
whereas in Monte Carlo tree search we
average the evaluations we just make
sure that we only ever go down promising
roots in the tree enough times that the
averaging is biased towards maximizing
and minimizing it's a nice robust search
technique and then as you probably know
this alphago
turned out to be much better than the
existing programs at the time which were
only at strong amateur level whereas
alphago the early version went into
professional territory and eventually
beat the strongest player in the world
at at this game and the evaluation was
first against fund why the European
champion and then later against Lisa toe
the Korean champion yeah
from 1990 comes more tractable so you
but you have to go to seven by seven I
think for it to be really tractable nine
by nine is still difficult and 11 by 11
is about as complex as stress so but
there's an interesting idea there we
talked about this these ever more
complex environments in the definition
of intelligence and one way to formulate
a curriculum over this task for example
would be to start learning on smaller
boards and hoping that you can have an
architecture that also works on bigger
boards and by learning on smaller boards
first you would have first successes and
a smaller space and you could learn some
basic patterns that would then transfer
to the to the larger boards I think that
could be a promising that could be a
promising route to address yeah yeah
that that is very interesting yeah it's
a smaller game it definitely is a
smaller game but it's good yeah people
have made progress they go from the
endgame positions backwards and from the
openings forwards and then at some point
they they match and and and can prove a
result okay and of course there's
there's more here and we will hope too
that Dave will cover this in in his
guest lecture of course recently we've
made a lot of progress whereas in this
earlier work we use supervised learning
to train these neural networks we used
games that were actually played by
humans and and use them as supervised
learning datasets taking a position and
a move as a classification problem
position is the input move is e is is
the class if you like and we were able
to train these networks but more
recently in the alphago zero work we can
do
this entirely through reinforcement
learning with the system only plays
against itself in and learn how to play
go even better than with human input
strangely and and then we also applied
that to chess but that's really just a
preview to today's lecture okay final
thing I would like to point you to some
extra revision material this was last
year included in the in the second
lecture which we've now replaced by the
tensor flow tutorial because we thought
that that was better use of the time but
if you want to take a look just at the
slides that we posted on Moodle there's
some basic revision of a regularization
generalization in supervised learning
and how gradient based learning works in
linear regression and in logistic
regression which are the models that
kind of lead up to to feed forward
neural networks then okay any questions
[Applause]
we're still trying to figure that out
there's a lecture cast recording and and
there's these recordings but so far we
haven't been able to combine them onto
Moodle so have to find out
yeah yeah no no I see what you mean I
see what you mean I mean the we were
very interested in this question
ourselves because in some sense you can
view these games as illustrations of
maybe what happens as we make AI
stronger and stronger so here we have
small worlds and we're now at the point
where the competence of the AI is
greater than the competence of humans in
this particular domain and so what does
that look like what is it like to play
against a higher intelligence so to
speak and maybe we can draw conclusions
that would also hold it for other
domains that are maybe even more useful
medical diagnosis or car driving or
whatever and so we were looking at this
and some of the moves that that alphago
made even during the first match in
Korea were pretty amazing according to
our experts so they were truly
surprising people were using the word
creative moves inventive moves because
some of the moves defied
well-established rules that human
players typically respect in their game
humans have a lot of heuristics that
they use to select moves because the
game is so complex but what that also
means is that they have certain biases
that is that are very hard for them to
overcome so if they have for example and
a trained pattern that tells them that a
particular move cannot possibly be good
but in this particular situation that
move happens to be the best move then a
lot of humans would have difficulties
finding that move because early on in
their reasoning they would rule it out
but alphago 'men have those limitations
or not to that degree at least and so it
came up with moves that were
counterintuitive to humans but when they
then saw how the game unfolds they
suddenly
realized how brilliant that move early
on was that they previously didn't
understand based just on their rules so
so that was pretty amazing to see and
then more recently we have some
interesting feedback on the chess games
that we published where we applied this
same methodology to chess and some of
the grandmasters were amazed at how
flexibly alpha 0 evaluates positions so
when you normally write a chess program
you would define an evaluation function
that tells you how good a given position
is and that would include the material
you know do you have more material than
your opponent queen king queen pawns and
so on it would include pawn structure
King safety mobility of your pieces and
so on and there but they would all have
some kind of fixed coefficient that the
programmer would have to put in so that
you can actually evaluate this function
and do a search based on it now the
alpha 0 approach doesn't have any of
those limitations it just learned this
general function from board state to
evaluation and as a consequence it's not
bound for example to the concept of
material so it much more easily
satisfies a piece in order to gain
positional advantage if it has learned
that in fact that increases its winning
probability and so sorry in some of the
games that we shared alpha 0 place a
sacrifice which is a positional
sacrifice it loses the piece and almost
no human player would do that unless
they knew exactly what they were getting
for it but alpha 0 was happy with that
move increasing its winning probability
and then somehow 40 moves later it would
get that home and actually win the game
and so that was pretty otherworldly in
terms of playing style and and chess
masters just just enjoyed those games a
lot yeah
and no it wasn't open sourced but there
are other programs other groups that
have in fact started reproducing this I
think there's an open source project
called Leela open Leela or something
Leela zero which is trying this and
there's also $0.10 the the Chinese
Internet company has a program called
fine art which is designed according to
the alphago specs and has become much
better in in recent times and is also
challenging professional players now we
published the algorithm and people can
implement that if they like but we
didn't open-source any of the code yeah
it's it's an interesting problem so what
alphago is trying to do is to maximize
its probability of winning when that
probability of winning is essentially at
100% then certain moves look the same
for alphago it can give away a point or
two if it's currently winning by five
points it doesn't care if it gives away
at one point or two and that seam can be
very frustrating for human opponents
because the moment you see you're you
know you
basically it doesn't care anymore yeah
it's an interesting problem I'm not sure
it can be solved while retaining the
playing strength that's an interesting
challenge because the criterion that we
use is winning probability and not
winning by a certain margin if we now
change the criterion and training to
from winning probability to please win
by the maximum possible margin then
there might be side effects like it
might start taking certain risks now to
win by a larger margin and so what what
you'd be asking for is really maintain
your high winning probability while at
the same time maximizing the margin of
winning that would lead to those non
slack moves and yeah it's it's tricky
maybe it can be done but I think our
research was mostly driven towards the
most principled question of maximize
winning probability and not not consider
the marginal okay I think we need to get
out of here thank you very much for your
attention
[Applause]